[Music]
let's bring you some breaking news
coming out of New Delhi India's top
court has given its verdict on the
disputed iodo religious site which is
claimed by Hindus and Muslims now we
understand it's ruled Muslims should be
given two hectares of land for a mosque
at an alternative site the central
government is to take control of the
land and prepare a roadmap in three
months to set up a Board of Trustees
possession of inner and outter land is
to be given to the government appointed
trust the court says the right of temple
construction on the disputed property is
subject to the maintenance of peace and
law and order and tranquility the
government is to take measures for
maintaining peace and harmony and lauren
order so an chal Vora joins us now live
from New Delhi so first of all there's a
lot to unpack here and so first of all
basically has it clearly ruled on the
question of ownership not just
possession who owns this land now which
is what the court was supposed to be
deciding
well you know not we haven't heard from
from the court on that exactly and the
court has been careful in what it has
said although I will add a caveat here
that we could perhaps wait for a longer
to read the judgment ourselves and
report accurately on it however I have
spoken to the analyst to understand the
same gap and they say that the land is
being the disputed land sammy is being
given to both of trustees government
appointed trustees this board would be
formed in three months and this board
essentially will decide how to go about
the construction of a ROM temple there
this is how the analysts understanding
the bits of judgment that we can confirm
to the viewers right now which means
that the disputed land is being given to
the Hindu side now to this case there
were three claimants one is Lord Rama
deity ROM himself and the court in the
proceedings today said that ROM is a
legal entity and the other was led mahir
Kara group of Hindu activists and the
third was a Sunni back for the Muslim
group the court has said that the the
acara people the Hindu activists their
claim is not a legit and they've kept a
lord ROM and the Sunni work more as the
two claimants and essentially thereby
also saying that the the land would be
divided between these two but it has not
been divided to clarify it's been given
to a board of trustees which will then
decide how to proceed with the
construction of the temple this is the
analysis of legal experts this is what
I'm picking up from the Muslims will get
five acres or two hectares of land
somewhere else
in the state of Uttar Pradesh where to
which as well as the disputed land is
and that's where they would be able to
build a mosque where that site would be
would could be decided by the central
government it could also be decided by
the state government now when we'd gone
to ayutthaya we'd actually found out the
Muslim intellectuals had already offered
this when the mediations took place
earlier this year as a possible
solution to have broader a peace between
the two communities but just to clarify
here is the way that this is being
characterized at least in the Indian
media is that this is a site where a
mosque once stood for hundreds of years
and it's now a Board of Trustee is going
to decide how to build a temple there or
simply what to do with the land
well how its being understood here
whether you talk about the Indian press
or whether we talk about the analysts
that we speaking to is that it's going
to be a board of trustees it will be
with a Board of Trustees which will be
formed in three months this we are clear
on and the analysis is that this board
of trustees would go ahead with the
construction of a temple in given time
this analyst is the reason behind this
analysis is because the court has
already clearly said that the Muslim
side the SUNY Board will get an
alternative piece of land so that's
where this analysis is really emerging
from so in a sense the court has been
slightly wygor maybe it hasn't been I
would like to paraphrase there and would
like to wait for the complete word ik to
read it myself but yeah that's how the
Indian press and the Indian analysts are
reading the judgment that the disputed
land will be with a board of trustees
who would then go about the construction
of Ram temple you're right this is where
for 400 years before 92 Babri mosque
stood that is understood but the court
has also said as a demolition of mosque
in 92 was a violation of law it has also
spoken about how Muslims trade in the
inner courtyard and the Hindus prayed in
the outer courtyard of this edifice and
they've also gone on to say that SUNY
buckboard could not prove exclusive
rights and that it was not so when it
when this began Sammy in 92 after Babri
mosque was demolished the first coat the
first case that went to the court was
whether there was a temple there whether
a mosque was built on top of a temple
was converted into a title suit which is
who does it belong to
but in this verdict the court has also
spoken about that according to the
Archaeological Survey of India a temple
existed at the site and that temple was
not demolished to build a mosque however
under the underlying structure where the
mosque was built back in if I'm right
1600 1700 centuries 400 years ago that
was there was an underlying structure
the Archaeological Survey of India's
findings do not specify whether the
structure was a temple or not however
the court has when I went on and said
that the Hindus for hundreds of years
believed that to be the birthplace of
Lord Rama deity Hindu deity bomb how
what sort of reaction are we getting to
this because the optics of it obviously
are not going to look very good for
Muslims in India and perhaps for Muslims
around the region well yes you know a
lot of calls have been made for peace a
lot of security arrangements have been
put in place but you know in the run-up
to this verdict we'd gone to our there
and we spoke to a lot of Muslim people
you hear one thing in a out there and
you hear something quite different in
the rest of the country in yoga there is
a lot of Hindus and Muslims live next
door to each other they're very friendly
and they say we have got no issues
whatever the word it is we are going to
accept but it's the outsiders when they
say the outsiders they mean that members
of the Hindu groups could come in and
cause some trouble and outside of
Ayodhya you know we hear these noises
but not while we are there the reaction
is something that cannot be judged
however people on the ground have said
that they would like to maintain peace
that they would accept whatever Supreme
Court's verdict is and Muslim
intellectuals that we'd interviewed said
that the mediations that took place
earlier this year in those mediations
they said that they would agree to such
a settlement and we've reported on this
before and the settlement being that you
give Muslims a piece of land somewhere
else
and there we could build a mosque that
could be a possible solution and a Hindu
activist groups have also agreed to this
solution the Hindu activist group then
it's it's a group called the VHP which
played a huge role or at least accused
of playing a huge role in the demolition
of Babri mosque they say they did not
actively ask their members to do it but
it somehow happened so these two groups
had some sort of a pre understanding it
seems before this verdict was given and
and the Muslim intellectuals have
clearly in this case played some sort of
a role because they are the ones
compromising however they said that
their precondition is that this should
not set a precedent for all other sites
which means that if Hindu activists
claim that other sites like Martha and
Kashi these are other areas in India
where Hindu groups say that there is a
mosque very close to a temple and it
should just be a mosque these are some
sort of claims that are made so the
Muslim intellectuals we apologize we
lost an Chell there let's take a closer
look at some of the backgrounds of this
controversy magenta was trying to
explain to us there that this - dates
back to 1855 over the ownership of about
a hectare of land claimed by both sides
the Hindus and Muslims where Hindus
believe it's the birthplace of one of
their main deities Lord Rama Hindu
groups say a temple was demolished to
build a mosque in the 16th century known
as Babri Masjid in 1992 hardline Hindus
who wanted to build the temple there
demolished the mosque that sparked
violence across the country 2,000 people
were killed most of them Muslims in 2010
judges in the Allahabad High Court ruled
that the land on which the mosque once
stood should be divided into three equal
parts one for Muslims and two for Hindus
well later that year both groups mounted
a legal challenge in the Indian Supreme
Court Sanjay Kapoor is editor of hard
news magazine he joins us now from New
Delhi good to have you with us so what
do you make of what we've heard so far
from this ruling that basically this
land will be handed over to a government
trust that is being characterized at
least
as a trust that will decide how to turn
the site of a mosque which was
demolished by a mob into a Hindu temple
yeah this is the judgment which was
expected but I don't think there is a
great amount of legal work that has gone
into coming to the judgment from a very
cursory reading of what has been coming
because if you flow the sea the flow of
the observations from the Supreme Court
they say the methods would believe for
the court cannot arbiter they can only
arbiter on matters of titles who owns
the land and from there you know they
you know certainly they encourage some
kind of a legal intervention suggesting
that who owned the land and there is
still a lot of confusion on who actually
owned the land but at the end that they
have decided I think this is a judgment
which has flown out of the mediation
that they had ordered way back in me and
long before the scores got into it the
Muslims are willing to give up their
land if there was a guarantee of sorts
that the other disputes will not be
opened up fundamentally the ones in
Mathura and and kashi the D which is the
parliamentary constituency of Prime
Minister Narendra Modi there - again you
have a Hindu temple as well as a Muslim
mosque standing cheek-by-jowl and they
are like really really major flash
points which could emerge if the
majority community Hindus are
triumphalist after the judgement so it
is a judgment which will have be very
closely watched there would be a lot of
interpretation which will come in but
very clearly I could see a fallacy of
one distributed middle which was showing
up for even for an untrained legal mind
as a journalist have been watching it
for many many years which suggests that
it flew in a certain direction it was
going in a certain direction and the
conclusion seemed to be a bit different
so I'm hoping that people who were being
exhausted by is very protected the
process that the trial as well as many
many cases that have come up from time
to time would take the entire judgment
in their stride and get on their life
because now the Muslims have been
offered five acres in in in the same
city gotiya and the Muslims would
probably take heart from the fact that
there is a recognition that there's been
some kind of
that has been done to the cause because
if I could jump it later
what kind of mixing here now two things
one is the the communal consultations
which were going underway and the Muslim
communities offer to give up the land
but that was in return for a request of
guarantees that any mosques pre I think
it was 1991 would not have their
legitimacy challenged we've had no
indication that indeed a court is not
the the venue for that sort of political
deal and we've had no indication that
that sort of guarantee has been given by
any authority right just to be clear
yeah absolutely right I mean the court
is not a place where these kind of
guarantees can be made I mean these what
what has to be a brought to the fore on
this issue has to come from the
government now as the Supreme Court has
said that loin art has to be maintained
and a lot of things have to be done so
I'm sure the government could take
cognizance in this but that is part of
the facts of this a problem that has
anyone from a law-and-order perspective
has anyone who has been implicated
including BJP leaders including Atal
Bihari Vajpayee who was a prime minister
at one point in India's government has
any of those figures who were associated
with the destruction of of a property
ever faced any legal consequences if
we're talking about law and order issues
so there has been a child which has been
going on for quite a while for when it
comes to the issue of demolition of the
Babri Masjid senior BJP leaders like mr.
LK Rani the former Deputy Prime Minister
and also the president of the party then
you have another one mr. Murli Manohar
Joshi then you have some allies of the
BJP from the Shiv Sena which is at four
at the moment in Maharashtra their
leaders were also being implicated but
you know the thing is that is so slow
and nothing really much has happened
despite the fact that today's Supreme
Court judgement declares that what
happened in on 6th of December 1992
was a clear violation of the Supreme
Court order they restrained people from
getting in and despite that you know
they got in and they brought down I mean
it happened in front of our eyes and it
was like so traumatic but it passes you
know and I'm sure with the the new
judgment that is going to be announced
the pace of whether we are able to find
a closure on the about the criminality
of this entire act would ever happen now
we understand a Board of Trustees is
going to be appointed are we basically
looking at the bjb Party which is of
course the central government and forms
the government of the state of utter
possession do they get to pick the
members of this board of trustees
absolutely I mean the entire burden has
been put on the government to put to
constitute a Board of Trustees and in
fact if you look at it there is
something called the Ram Janmabhoomi
niaz which is actually a trust which has
been also hand which is the one which
will be beefed up or populated by the
government about who should be in it so
there is there is a you know it's
basically the government which will for
you know I acquired two point seven
seven acres of land plus a 67 acres they
already have so there is a huge land
which would be available for as they
kept on saying a magnificent Hindu
temple around temple so it is going to
be a government thing so the trust is
going to work under the government
instructions or supervision all right
we'll leave it there thanks so much for
your analysis and India's Prime Minister
Narendra Modi has tweeted appealing for
calm whatever decision the Supreme Court
arrives at on IO dia it will not be a
victory or defeat of anyone I appealed
to the countrymen that all of us
prioritized that this decision should
further strengthen India's great
traditions of peace unity and goodwill